the presiding judge says the evidence
against azure data is overwhelming in
addition the court says he has made a
written confession of involvement in the
murder
the dayev comes from chechnya and
russian's northern caucasus region he
spent 10 years serving in a police unit
there tadayev was arrested in the
neighboring autonomous region of in
gushetia
i love the prophet muhammad no one else
tadayev calls testily to journalists and
onlookers in the courtroom
the prosecutors allege these men are his
accomplices
like dadayev they also hail from the
northern caucasus but all of them have
denied involvement in the killing
one of them anzor gubashev was also
charged and remanded in custody he and
his brother were arrested saturday in
ingoshetya
soon afterwards russian television crews
located gubashev's family in the village
of mal gobek
they are relatives they are very good
boys and did well in school i can't say
lived their lives along with all of us
just over a week has passed since
nyemsof was gunned down within sight of
the kremlin and prosecutors have issued
no motive the suspects might have had to
killing him